dear mom do you ever wonder about the
moment you became you the moment that
decides how we forever look at the world
for me it was with you hello mother I
thought maybe we can hang out a little
bit gotta catch the subway i'm gonna
lose you i know you're confused in part
i am too i don't know how I'm supposed
to feel right
I thought it would be best for the baby
to give her up you wrote that every day
don't you realize life is short and I
love you and I have not seen you you've
been completely off your path are you on
something how much y'all into it it's so
easy for men right they think that they
have forever you're pregnant what how
long do I have geez is that a death
sentence some people can't see the love
they have until they see it through
someone else's eyes fashion week has
been all abuzz Wow mothers come in all
shapes and sizes just lucky happy
sometimes there for just a moment give
is beautiful figure hairs
and sometimes they remain for a lifetime
to mothers who by any other name just as
sweet
today is Mother's Day and I remember
everything about you you go